bleurgh which is directed by Adam
Wingard who made the guest a movie that
I really enjoyed and really surprised me
I'll never forget my theater experience
with a guest
really fun movie and actually one of my
favorite movies of that year so
naturally I was looking forward to this
movie plus the Blair Witch Project was
very impactful for my generation I
remember being in school in 1999 and
every single kid was talking about this
movie and you can actually go back and
read reviews from critics from 1999 who
were like um mommy the marketing for the
original movie was really on point with
this film Adam Wingard did something
very similar he marketed the film as the
woods a lot of people thought it was
going to be that film and we didn't know
what it was but he revealed this was
going to be the third Blair Witch film a
continuation of the 1999 film in which
the brother of Heather in that film goes
back to Burkittsville looking for her
and brings a lot of cameras and some
more friends and of course
shit happens that's not fun for them but
you know when compared to other
found-footage movies that I've seen over
the past few years ever since the Blair
Witch Project revitalized the genre this
is definitely one of the better ones
Adam Wingard is a director that
understands how to build tension and
build fear and really let that explode
and the part in this film worried
explodes the last 10 minutes were great
that's what I wanted this film to be
like the last 10 minutes of this movie
are very scary very unsettling and I
actually did shake a little bit in my
legs they got a little bit shaky
unfortunately what comes before that is
essentially a complete rehash of the
original a lot of people are saying this
right now and I didn't want to believe
it but in all honesty this film is
almost a beat for beat re-creation of
the Blair Witch Project it doesn't have
the interviews from the townspeople or
Burkittsville but they still do go out
into the woods they get lost they're
camping there are sounds at night there
are twigs there are rocks there's a
house you know the stuff that we all
have seen already and that was
disappointing I was expecting a little
more innovation beyond a drone that
sometimes flies up and gets overhead
shots I wanted more than just what we
had already seen and the last 10 minutes
does extend more
than the original gave us and that bit
of extension I was like okay that's some
serious shit right there also something
occurred in the last 10 minutes that
made me think of the rest of the film in
a different light without spoiling it
there is definitely something strange
going on some kind of weird circle of
Blair Witch Death and it made the rest
of what I had already seen a little more
profound and it definitely changed the
film and I like that about it and this
brings me to the remember the fucking
jump scares at least like five or six
times somebody jumps in front of the
camera goes hey and it's like why why
would you do that multiple times over
and over again it's so cheap it really
is very cheap and I know that Adam
Wingard is above that and for some
reason they keep happening it's not
scary people it's a sound it's not
frightening okay and no one would do
that you're in the woods you're already
scared and with your friends why the
hell would you just like purposely make
this incredibly loud sound right behind
them like it's so in the past year or so
I have seen jump scares diminish I think
that Hollywood directors are actually
hearing people and myself and other
people who are saying you know stop with
the frickin jump scares and it's
actually started to fade out of horror
movies a little bit and then here we go
with fucking a billion jump scares just
people jumping everywhere it's dumb it's
stupid there's way too many of them in
this movie the last 10 minutes are
legitimately scary but the entire like
first hour is just all these false
scares over and over again that do
nothing that was majorly disappointing
and that is my rant on the jump scares
now that I have gotten that out of the
way I can talk about what's positive
again the performances are actually very
strong there is a little overacting at
times but overall the performances are
very good I'll say this if you really
liked the first Blair Witch Project you
will probably enjoy this movie if you
hated it you will absolutely hate this
movie like I'm almost positive like
99.9% sure if you hated the Blair Witch
Project you're probably going to hate
this because they are very similar I'll
be honest with you I was at a cc+
for the majority of this movie but those
last 10 minutes I think did help the
movie and it made me think differently
about what I had already seen and for
that reason I'm going to give Blair
Witch a b-minus it's disappointing that
it's so similar to the first one and
those jump scares they need to go the
fuck away but overall I did find some
enjoyment in this movie and I think that
fans of the original can still find the
same enjoyment that I found what do you
guys think this movie if you saw it also
please check out audible.com slash Kris
these guys have been kind enough to
sponsor my videos they have an absurd
amount of audiobooks hundreds of
thousands and you can have a 30-day free
trial if you go to audible.com slash
Kris thank you so much to audible for
continuing to sponsor my videos and
thank you guys because you're the best
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]